Hello, and welcome to this new lesson. Today we're going to be taking about
Array Lists. An Array List collects objects and all the objects in the Array
List need to be of the same type. Now what would we like to collect? Me,
personally I'd like to collect valuable paintings. So let's see how we would do
that in Java. Here you see the rather long declaration of an Array List that
can collect pictures. Let's work through the pieces. We're declaring a
variable, called gallery, its type is an ArrayList, but whenever we have an
ArrayList we need to also specify the type of the objects that it collects.
That's the pictures here, so the whole thing here, ArrayList of picture, is the
type of the gallery object. To the right you simply have a constructor call,
where you again have to type ArrayList of picture. We have the new operator,
because we make a new object off the ArrayList type and the parenthesis here
simply mean that we pass nothing to the constructor. What we get is an empty
ArrayList, which can, as we add them in, hold as many pictures as we like.
Here, we add a couple of pictures to the gallery. The add method, takes as its
argument, the object that we want to add. Once you've added objects to an Array
List, you'll want to be able to do something with the contents. Let's look at
that next